اختارت ابشع طريقه لتنفيذ خطتها المجنونه
منشار كهربائي استخدمته لقطع يد بشريه لكن
الصدمه انها لم تعتدي على احد وانا الضحيه
كانت هي نفسها
الاسم يوليا ادليزيتش التهمه الاحتيال
المكان سلوفينيا الحكم السجن لمده عامين
في اوائل عام 2019 خطرت على بالي الشابه
سلوفينيه
ذات 22 عاما حينها خطه احتيال درستها بدقه
بمشاركه صديقها الخطوه الاولى من الخطه
بدات عندما وقعت يوليا عقودا مع خمس شركات
تامين مختلفه بقيمه تعويضات تتجاوز
المليون يورو لكن الخطوه التاليه اقل ما
يقال عنها انها كانت مجنونه ولا يمكن ان
يتقبلها اي انسان عاقل حتى لو كان محتالا
الخطوه الثانيه من الخطه كانت ان تقطع
يوليا يدها بواسطه منشار كهربائي للادعاء
بانها تعرضت لحادث وبالتالي يتم الحصول
على مبالغ التعويضات من شركات التامين
وبالفعل اقدمت الشابه على قطع يدها اليسرى
فوق منطقه الرسغ وهرعت مع صديقها الى
المستشفى زاعمه انها اصيبت اثناء قيامها
بقطع اغصان الاشجار
من ذلك انها تعمدت عدم اخذ يدها المقطوعه
معها ليصبح من المستحيل خياطتها وتتحول
يوليا الى معاقه بشكل لا رجعت فيه
وبالتالي تحصل على مبالغ التعويض كان من
المفترض ان تحصل الفتاه على نصف مبالغ
التامين على الفور والباقي على دفعات
شهريه منتظمه لكن النيابه العامه في
سلوفينيا تمكنت من كشف اللعبه خلال
التحقيقات تبين ان صديقي يوليا كان يبحث
قبل ايام قليله على الانترنت عن معلومات
حول كيفيه عمل الايدي الاصطناعيه وهو دليل
اضافي على انهما اقدم على فعلتهما عن قصد
وان الامر لم يكن حادثا تم القبض على
يوليا وصديقها وبدل حصولهما على المليون
يورو المنتظره قضت المحكمه بسجن الفتاه
لمده عامين بتهمه الاحتيال وسجن صديقها
لثلاثه اعوام بتهمه التحريض يوليا دافعت
عن براءتها خلال المحاكمه واصرت على ان
الامر كان حديثا معتبره انما من عاقل في
العالم يقدم على قطع يده بملء ارادته
اريد ان يصاب بالشلل لقد تم تدمير شبابي
فقد يتيه في سن العشرين انا فقط اعرف كيف
حدث ذلك
نعتقد ان الاحكام عادله ومناسبه وسوف تفي
بالغرض منها
الاخبار الجيده ليوليا كانت انها لم تقضي
فتره سجنها بيد واحده فبعد وصولها الى
المستشفى تمكنت فرق الاسعاف من احضار يدها
المقطوعه على وجه السرعه واعاده ربطها في
اللحظات الاخيره لكن من غير المعلوم حتى
اللحظه مدى الضرر الذي تعرضت له والقدره
على استخدامها بشكل طبيعي خصوصا انها كانت
تحرص على اخفاء يدها طوال فتره محاكمتها